we're set up to film these salmon but
they keep darting away hey what the heck
grizzly bear Paul wax camera out of
position and jettisons at downstream now
that was not supposed to happen
Bob hey there's the bear and here she is
again with her cubs
yes it's springtime in Alaska and this
mother grizzly is teaching her young
ones how to fish so they can feed
themselves I mean it's not like the fish
just jump out of the water in your mouth
well okay I mean sometimes they do but
it's all the matter of being in the
right place at the right time this time
of year
rivers are teeming with fish and the
mother grizzly is traveling to the exact
same spot where her own mother taught
her how to NAB sand
okay mom has finally arrived at her
teaching spot she spreads her rear legs
for balance and directs her laser-like
glare into the current when she gets the
opportunity she'll grab a fish as it
clears the water
or handed under one with her paw
mom's trying to teach but one of her
cubs isn't even watching when mom
finally makes a picture-perfect ground
that's when they notice what she's doing
probably because lunch has arrived okay
well that's enough work for one day but
these lessons have to be work a
full-grown grizzly can eat 50 pounds of
food a day